stop okay
she's literally gonna go until they were
over this
we should have come last night and you
knew it all that drama is about to
unfold on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians but thankfully in real life
things seem to be going well for Khloe
Kardashian and Tristan Thompson yeah it
seems that way she just was cheering on
her man at his basketball game but could
she be gearing up for a move across the
country I don't know the signs are there
I'm Kourtney says the note joined by
Halle Stevens while it was a tough loss
for Tristan and his team it seems like
Khloe is getting pretty comfortable in
Ohio and a lot of signs like I said are
pointing to a big change in the family
yeah but before she makes that big
change she has a little bit of
celebrating to do with her reality TV
family a source tells e.t she may fly
back for mom kris Jenner's V day next
week but it all depends on how things
are going with Tristan okay so we know
Kris is not gonna have it Khloe has to
be at her birthday party but let's go
ahead and talk about Chloe and Tristan
we know they've had a rocky history
after Tristan's alleged cheating scandal
back in April and they went public about
their relationship in September 2016 so
it's about two years now so I feel like
they may be in a sweet spot to talk
about taking that next step to move to
Cleveland what do you think I hope so I
mean I'd like to see these Kardashian's
in long-term relationships that's kind
of unusual for them and I'd like to see
them work it out I'm a champion for love
exactly okay so here's what our easy
source says Khloe and Tristan are still
working on things as a couple but
whatever they do they want to do
whatever's best for baby true as any
parent would want to but I kind of think
that the Internet is reading into this
one where they're saying that because of
the alleged cheating scandal she is
purposely not talking about Tristan
right Chloe recently posted this
super-sweet pic of her and baby true to
Bali in Bali and she captioned it with
this thankful for the memories baby true
and I are creating of course the
Internet did what the Internet does and
they said she was throwing shade at
Tristan by not mentioning him do you
think this is a disk by omission
I don't think though I think people are
reading into it and just because she
doesn't talk about him on social media
doesn't mean that they're at odds
really silly okay so we have some new
hints that Chloe could be moving to
Cleveland because mom Kris Jenner went
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show and she
played the burning questions game is
Kylie trying for another baby I don't
know
is Chloe moving to Cleveland maybe do we
think it's a good decision for Khloe to
move in with Tristan Thompson following
the scandal okay so here's a few things
I really feel like the Kardashians are
all about family they constantly said
family is first and I really want to see
more of those cousin pictures because
they're too cute
if Chloe moves there's going to be few
and few of those sessions so I really
feel like she's gonna be missing out on
that so it's a loss for me I hear you I
mean I kind of feel for her I think she
has to move if she wants to keep her
family together but man they like I've
got to imagine they lost a lot of trust
and she couldn't do a long-term
relationship with him after everything
they went through so yeah kind of and
it's a lose-lose she either moves to
Cleveland and she misses her family or
she stays in LA and she misses Tristan
it's just a lot to dig into you guys so
you let us know how you're feeling
building back trust is a process we all
know that do you think Chloe interest in
moving away from the Kardashian crew
could actually help them let us know
yeah and let us know what you think of
Chloe's post the one with true I mean do
you think she was just being private and
protecting her relationship with Tristan
where do you think she was throwing some
serious shade I don't know but let's
keep the conversation going
all across social media are you guys
okay with Chloe moving to Ohio and
making that her permanent home until
next time we've got you covered on your
pop culture fix bye for now